Hi, this is Alex and I am a very patient officer. How are you doing today?
I'm doing fine.
Great. Good evening, Heather.
Well, as you know, this is annual enrollment related for 2020.
2021 hasn't started.
So today, my job is to make sure that you receive all these new
or additional benefits on your Medicare policy at no cost.
So just you can format.
You have Medicare for A and B.
What company is this?
I'm calling you for Medicare benefits and savings.
And we currently working with 25 corporate insurance companies
carriers, like United House sales, Vietnam, Romana,
Etc. Now Blue Cross push is.
And then basically our job is to connect with our other income.
You need to get your job space and benefits.
You're missing right now, okay?
I have a question.
Yes, I'm pleased for it.
Why is it every time y'all call here?
Y'all call here every day?
You know, ma'am.
You know, you just want to throw it to me.
I'm not calling you.
Y'all call me.
You're personally all here every day, all day.
And on the call ID, it's always a different number.
Hold on.
You know, you know, you know, ma'am, it's not always formal.
You need to clear some over working with us.
But definitely, as you are sampling of it as well, okay?
Like this, what are you?
I definitely forward the complaint.
But now you're in a good sense, okay?
And these persons are not from over.
It's directly from over company.
They just work with us, okay?
Okay.
So I just want...
Anyway, just put me on the DNC list.
Now, if I put your number on schedule to not call it,
you know, just any updates, any calls from their Medicare,
any from any of the insurance as well.
So will that be okay?
If I put your number and do not call it, then I want you
what you call you.
I'm not sure if I'm actually talking this on one form,
Medicare, Medicaid, or whoever.
I'm not sure.
This is who I'm talking to.
That's why I'm skeptical when you all call me,
because my IDP sent other names,
but you're saying you're someone else when I answer.
Exactly.
I know.
I know you're subconscious about your calls,
but now I'm ready to provide you my old information just
for your company.
Like, my name is Alex Miller,
and my ID is 7-8-AM-98,
and I'm calling you from Medicare, Benefit, and City.
And then Medicare is usually working from nationwide,
but we are going to be working from
pay-effects-stomping with you now, okay?
So now, my goal is just to make sure that you receive
all the benefits that you're missing right now
in this annual enrollment period,
because a lot of changing happened in this annual enrollment period,
okay?
And I'm going to work.
What's the number so that I can call them?
Because I can't talk for it now.
All right.
Now, my mom, I'm not able to provide you my official number,
like, if you want to read a text,
I'm just going to write something on the line in your state,
and it definitely provides your official website as well,
and our official call-back number as well,
then you're able to read a text,
or it's going to help my number, okay?
But, and on this call-back,
I'm not going to need any of your personal information
like your bank account.
I just need your basic details,
but it's just for your safety,
to make sure I'm speaking with a life portion, okay?
That's why I just need your,
I just want to verify your name, your zip code,
and your age, that's it, okay?
I don't need any personal information.
So now, I have your permission to go ahead
and review your plans to make sure you're not missing anything,
and you can get all the benefits
and make sure you qualify for this research today.
So, you want me to give you information
to verify that I'm who I stand in,
but I have no ways to verify
if you are who you really say you are.
I'll show you.
Now, I provide you my ID,
you may write it down,
and when I connect your calls with one of the legal medical adviser
in your areas,
then you may be gratifying, okay?
Yes, okay.
All right.
So, let me go ahead now.
So, you know, the purpose of our call,
this mindset of this room,
just to make sure that you receive all the benefits
that you're making right now,
and just annual involving surveys.
So, I'm just to confirm,
like, do you have medical costs,
A and B, right?
Yes.
And now, how old are you?
56.
56, I got it.
And now, are you disabled?
Yes.
Okay.
What kind of disability you have?
I have to add a call.
I have to write it,
and a whole lot of the stuff.
Oh, so sorry to hit that.
Okay.
Just give me a second.
All right.
New York last morning.
And I believe you make your own medical decision, right?
Yes.
Perfect.
And may I speak with Lisa?
Yes.
All right.
So, Lisa, now, are just to find out the best benefits for you.
Let me ask you this.
Would you pay any call fees whenever you visit your doctor
or specialist?
No.
This time, no.
You don't feel perfect.
And then, do you have a dental,
patient, and healing coverage at the moment?
Yes.
Perfect.
And then, are you having a second-grade insurance,
like Humana, Edna, Blue Cross,
four-series, United House,
stigma,
which second-grade insurance you have?
Does that really matter?
Yes.
Exactly.
I want you to know that it's the least we work with,
or this area or not.
I'm able to help you,
because I tell you that we work with 25 store-per-rated insurance
carriers, we not work with the local carriers.
That's why I want you to know, like,
we work with United House,
healthcare, stigma, Edna, Blue Cross,
four-series, United House,
and many of them, like Edna.
So, I want you to know that,
which advantage Medicare policy you have?
Two men.
Perfect.
We also give you two men as well.
Two men, if you have human insurance,
are you receiving $170 cashback
on your social security check every month?
Am I receiving what?
Are you receiving $170 cashback
on your social security check every month?
Is there $170?
Yes.
How's the price?
And then do you have a black card?
Do you know what it's a black card?
Look.
I'll explain you.
This is a well, if you get the black card,
you can get the huge discount on your grocery shopping.
Do you remember,
shape on your medical equipment,
fort-alongs,
it's black card,
and what's the counter-benefit?
And then you can get all the benefits through black cards.
All right?
So now, today, what we can do for you,
as you know,
the triangle enrollment period for 2023,
so a lot of changes happen
in the triangle enrollment period.
So now, today, we simply help you
to review your plans to make sure
you're not missing anything.
And then, if you're missing out,
the benefit says,
we definitely provide you
at no cost, is you.
And then, the charges,
there are some other benefits
like medical alert systems,
free consultations,
like stars.
And for this year,
now, Daniel is increased
up to $750,000,
and $155 forward the counter-benefit.
And then, you may qualify
for all these benefits,
as no cost to use,
which sounds to see.
All right.
So now, I just need to verify
some basic details.
Now, you're difficult.
As you call?
Yes.
Two, three,
two, three,
three, four,
three, three,
three,
four,
four, three,
four, five,
three,
four, three,
four,
four, seven,
four, three,
four, one,
four, two,
four, three,
two, three,
four,
five,
Perfectly, it's a dashboard and to my side and you perfectly qualify.
So, now I'm just going to license it on the line and see how to resume your plans and
tell you that for which plan for it's available for you in the annual enrollment period and
for which plan for it to be qualified for it.
So, now before I get a specialist for you, I just want you to make sure that you have
your right-wise and blue color nature house insurance card in hand because it's been
helped you rise your conversation with a legal Medicare advisor.
So, Lisa, do you have the card in hand or you have to go and get it?
Yes, I have a good.
Okay, is it in your hand?
Yes.
Okay, let me verify your card now.
If you see on the front side of the card, you will see Medicare house insurance on top,
then your name and then your Medicare number, right?
Yes.
Now, what is written below your Medicare number?
Yes, below your Medicare number.
Oh, there's a hospital and a medical A&D.
Exactly.
Now, you perfectly qualify and I'm just going to be holding a right card.
So, Lisa, that's all I'm going to say now, and you perfectly qualify and I'm before
you.
I just want to play a short, record a disclaimer on the call asking your permission to give
you a call back.
If in case we get disconnected on this call and if the license agent needs to send you something
inviting.
Okay.
So, now, I'm just going to be recording this and please say yes at the end of the recording
and I'll bring a license agent for you.
Very good.
Before we proceed, I need your electronic voice signature that is the same as getting our
children's consent to receive marketing communications regarding insurance products and services.
That automated dining system and it will be recorded calls by our company or its partners
or its license insurance agents at the phone number we are using today, including wireless
numbers.
And it will override all federal or state telemarketing and do not call laws.
This consent is not required as a condition to purchase our services or products.
If you agree to give your prior expression consent, please say yes.
Okay.
Perfect.
I got it.
So, Lisa, that's holding from my side and then you perfectly qualify.
So, now, I'm just playing the license agent on the line and then when the license agent
comes on the line and if you ask you, how can I help you or what can I do for you?
Now, you simply mentioned that if you want to see that three transfers available for you
in this annual enrollment series and for this month, where do you call the 540?
All right.
And now, is this the best number to reach back if we get disconnected on the phone?
757?
493?
0011, man.
Is this the best number to reach back if we get disconnected on the phone?
Yes.
Great.
Getting it out.
And by the way, how's your day going so far?
I'm so lazy.
Oh, all right.
I got it.
And I'm also rattling between yesterdays.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
So, now, I'm just going to next year call and maybe the screener come on the line before I get
a specialist.
So, now, he just needs your first and the last name, your sister and your eight.
And then he brings other.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
All right.
I'm just playing the license agent on the line.
And then maybe the screener come on the line.
He just needs your eight, your sister and your first and the last name.
Then he brings a license agent for you.
And then I'm still with you under the license agent, not come on the line.
Okay.
So, please stay on the line with me here with you.
Yes, please, sir.
Thank you for calling to review your Medicare options.
Calls me over to the quality of time.
Hi.
I just want to show on a recommended line.
It's my pleasure to assist with your annual enrollment benefits.
Do you have Medicare cards A and B?
Yes.
Okay, great.
Let's get to over to a license agent to review your options to make sure you have the best plan available for next year.
Okay, you can have your first and last name.
Please vote.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you, Mrs. Luffington.
A license agent will join us shortly.
When they do, you will hear a short compliance recording.
After this recording, I'll do a brief introduction.
Please stay on the line until this is complete.
For compliance to your awareness, it's for compliance to your awareness.
This interaction is not associated with any promotional monetary value.
Just bear with me here.
We should be getting somewhere shortly.
I thought she was here.
I made a quick closing.
We do not offer every time available in your area.
Any information you provide is limited to those services you offer in your area.
If you don't have to mediate about the other one, you will need to mediate this information on all of your options.
Yeah, I have Lisa Luffington here.
zip code is 23707.
Did birth as June 21, 1966.
Interested in everything?
Options for annual enrollment?
Okay, Lisa, thank you.
It's been my pleasure.
You both have a great day.
You too.
Thank you.
All right, Lisa.
How are you today?
All right.
This is Jeremy.
It was luck last year.
Looking to help you get Medicare coverage here.